once the oranges have been cut okay put
them onto the plate while that fingers
under please now this is where it starts
to take on a completely different level
okay oranges on the plates now here we
go this is exciting time mint that's gay
and coriander cut the stalks off okay
I'll do you as underway into the blender
okay and get the sugar and you blend the
coriander in the mid in what we can do
is make a really nice wonderful herb
sugar boy let me father yours okay into
your blender yeah yeah there you go
your guy yeah well done now give that
little shake okay what we're doing is
getting a really nice sort of scented
marinade the sugars going to be
sprinkled on top of the oranges and it
just starts to sort of elevate the whole
thing now that smells amazing
mmm little snow mmm nice nice lovely oh
yeah right
okay can you faster give a little shook
little shake well done that's it good no
okay same out yeah good I shave let me
see gentle with it there you go
excellent now okay sprinkle over the
oranges now this is where the oranges
sort of start to marinate and the
coriander of the mint start to sort of
penetrate the orange is absolutely
delicious generously on there well done
now probably got it okay usually after
Polygram is on top yes now I brunch the
pomegranate group the pomegranate juice
is delicious the oranges pomegranates on
well done good now if you've got a
piping bag at home use if I'm gonna make
my own parchment paper and if we don't
you say that I can make yours as well
from there a little triangle yeah right
to left nice and sharp and look on into
the bag and there as you make a batch
now put a couple of tablespoons of
yogurt in your flagging bag okay yeah
well done again cross so sorry
hold it over right the left nice and
tight find that point and this is where
we start to put a nice sauce on there
don't go crazy in there just a couple of
tablespoons nice in okay
I wish you've said you got you know when
you say say at the beginning of the
fender follow this happy now cut off the
end Oh your piping bag a little bit okay
and look nicely drizzle the yogurt over
the oranges okay on it goes and this
adds a little sort of tartness to the
dessert absolutely delicious and there
we have that's the bomb biologies gun